consider the numbers 1 3 7 and negative
15 2 which sets of numbers listed below
does each of these numbers belong so
let's think about the sets first and
then that'll make it pretty
straightforward to think about what what
what sets these guys are members of so
natural numbers you can kind of view
these as the counting numbers this is 1
2 3 4 5 6 or another way to think about
it's the whole numbers except for 0 so 0
is not in the natural numbers it starts
at 1 1 2 3 4 so on and so forth
whole numbers is the natural numbers
plus 0 plus 0 integers are the whole
numbers plus the negative versions of
the natural numbers then rational
numbers these are any numbers that can
be represented by a fraction irrational
numbers cannot be represented by a
fraction and then real numbers are
essentially all of these so let's think
about the numbers that they gave us so
let's first think about 1/3 so 1/3 is
not a counting number it's not a whole
number it's a fraction it's not an
integer it's a fraction it is a rational
number it can clearly be represented as
a fraction so I'll write it over here
1/3 is a rational number it's not an
irrational number there's nothing that's
part of both the rational and the
irrational is you have to pick between
one of those two but it's clearly a real
number so 1/3 is rational and it is real
so let's do 7 here so 7 is a natural
number you can when you count things you
can count up to 7 it's definitely a
whole number in fact anything that's a
natural number is also going to be a
whole number and anything that's a
natural number or a whole number is also
going to be an integer is also going to
be an integer
anything that is a natural number a
whole number an integer is also going to
be a rational number because you can
represent this as 7 over 1 7 is equal to
7 over 1 and you can do this with any
with any integer you can just say it's
the same thing as that over 1 so you can
represent it as a fraction so it's
clearly not irrational but it's going to
be real it's going to be
real and then finally you might be
saying hey why do we even care about
real numbers in the future we'll be
introduced to things called imaginary
and complex numbers and those aren't
real so but most of the numbers that
you've dealt with so far they're going
to be real numbers so let's just finish
up with negative 15 over here negative
15 is not a counting number it's not a
natural number it's not one two three so
on and so forth it's not a whole number
because that would just be zero plus one
two three four five it is an integer
though it is an integer so it is
negative 15 is right over here you can
view you can view natural numbers as all
positive integers you could view whole
numbers as all non-negative integers and
of course integers will include negative
and non-negative integers and that's
where negative 15 is going to sit
negative 15 can be represented as a
rational number can be negative 15 over
one so we're gonna put negative 15 right
over here if it's rational it can't be
irrational and it's got to be a real and
it's going to be a real number and we
are done